hi as I promised I'm finally making my
way through the tutorial request list
and today we have a tutorial on BM
sit-downs
or BM flawless layouts and this is
something that's been requested quite a
while ago and I would figure I would do
it anyway since it hasn't really been
done before and I still sometimes see
people struggling with this stuff so I
don't really have too much to say over
here really I think we will all just
figure that out while we're building our
stuff here excuse me for using the
extended track of the in-game thing
right now I don't even think I have a BM
sit down or flawless CTR so that's kind
of this is what we have to deal with at
the moment basically so yeah actually I
only place that station but I wouldn't
like to turn it talked a tiny bit about
that I usually raise my stations about 4
tiles don't ever place them on the
ground stations are always raised to
some level usually it is about 2 meters
so 2 times raising it 2 times 4 times
sometimes 6 6 times that's about the
height that you want to have as you may
have noticed I didn't name any numbers
but though you can do that that also
results in an odd placement and that
sometimes kind of hard to work with for
the length of the station I would go
somewhere between 5 and 7 tiles both for
practical reasons and making this
station for that I always like to make
mine 6 tiles we don't often go straight
into the lift hill this is something
that really does happen in real life but
I think over here it might actually be
better to just kind of move this thing
so over here I would like to start the
lift Hill I always like to play some
breaks just before that just so the car
can slow down but also so you can add
that little motor underneath it where
the lift Hill is going to go up and just
at the lift Hill there really isn't too
much to this thing yet it doesn't really
matter what you're going to do at that
point and as you may have noticed I
turned on the heights for the track and
even though this seems like a pretty
useless thing to do it can sometimes
actually be very handy as I'm going to
show in a second right here for example
right now we're on 26 meters and this is
a very common height for lift hills and
rollercoaster can 3 since this means you
can have a steep slope
have it end in a way like this and have
it cursed not yet close the ground reach
the ground since we don't really want
the tractor touch the ground but we also
don't want it to levitate too high like
this is about the right height that the
track should be from the ground usually
and when you have a drop that's this
high you can kind of just make a small
coaster you can add a loop like that and
as you can see that is a pretty good
high to stop to start doing stuff like
that it really just comes down to what
kind of height you want to have you can
also just kind of go up over here I
think that should be good to actually
you know that's one too high
basically you're always kind of looking
for that exact spot in height where as
you go down you just levitate two meters
above the ground that is right about the
right height now looking at this this is
still kind of high I wouldn't want to
make it too large for this tutorial this
is definitely a height that you can do
for example if you want to build a
really really high coaster then and it's
actually not the right height no if you
want to build a really high B&M sit down
this is about the height that you want
to go for about 42 meters since now you
can go down like that
and start off with large loops or large
0g rows actually not that yet
but I would like to go down just a tiny
bit go back to 26 just for the sake of
this tutorial that was just a tiny bit
about the height of lives Hill so it
really just comes down to what like how
high you want to make your roller
coaster but make sure it is at such a
height where you can add a smooth drop
that also comes down to a very
reasonable height at the end something
which many people do is also just kind
of curve it around like that and then at
leaping that's actually a very common
thing which also has a perfect height
for that so that's the stuff that you
can try out and you may have noticed
that I added a little dip around here
which is the pre trop now if you don't
know pre drop is a very small drop
before the final really big drop and
actually it's the first drop before the
big drop comes just to get rid of some
tension on the cable because otherwise
you kind of stress the cables too much
if you go down right away and the car
would pull the cable down
but this is actually only something to
worry about when you're building an old
B and M sit down I know this this sounds
a little bit silly but the first B&M sit
down the early generation ones always
had this little pretty drop to get rid
of that tension on the cable but the
newest ones don't have that they don't
need that anymore so it really depends
on how old you want to make your ride
like if you want to put a B and M sit
down in a park that's pretty old
otherwise and just it just kind of
depends on the story of your park I
always like to have no pre drop sins
really they kind of look a bit silly
sometimes so I would say that with a
curve like this it is actually something
that I'd really like to have so yeah I
think right now it's a it's actually a
good time to start adding a curve so
that is the first drop very important
thing in coaster building at this point
you don't really need the heights too
much I always just find them kind of
distracting so yeah first drop and
usually what beam amps do is you have
the lift Hill you get the first drop a
couple of elements and then you either
get a mid-course brake run or you get
like the ending of the right and it kind
of just depends on how large your ride
is whether you want to have a met cause
brake run or not a mate cause brake run
is when it kind of goes up and has a
couple of breaks and then goes down
again this really depends on while both
the speed of your ride like if you want
to slow it down you would have to add
one of these things if it's a really
large right you have to admit cause
brake runs just for safety reasons most
likely but if you have a small right
like this if it's just about 26 meters
high I wouldn't worry about that too
much like only add a brake run on such a
very small coaster if you really need
one in any case I'll just kind of kind
of continue with this usually what be a
mess have for the first couple of
elements before they go into the brake
run or the ending of the ride is they do
a couple of inversions some other small
elements like over banked curves and
things like that but no helixes yet in
the first half of the ride you want to
stay away from things like the large
helix that rarely ever happens like it
happens unlike a couple of stand-up
coasters that thenahms may
but then higher helixes it's kind of
complicated but it's nothing it's not
really something that I would recommend
to do to skip it to the higher elements
and things like that so now there's a
couple of things that most benhams have
in the first part before the MCB are the
mid-course brake run is there is a
looping that you can add you can add a
Cobra roll which is very common elements
which is when you have a looping and
they get a corkscrew another corkscrew
in the different direction and then
another half loop it's a very common
elements but something that's also quite
common on the first half of a BM sit
down is a tsurujirô
I don't think it's too good of an idea
to add them over here because as you can
see it is a very large element and it
really doesn't fit in the first half of
the ride usually I go with like a
looping a Cobra roll and something else
for the first half of the ride so for
this ride I would actually say a small
little fun element and then go into the
Cobra roll that would seem like a pretty
fun thing to do I'm RELIGIOUS making
hair stuff up in the spot right here so
I'm very sorry if this is going to turn
out in to like actually a terrible
roller coaster hopefully that's not the
case but just kind of winging it as well
here also by the way I just showed it
with a small corkscrew but every single
roller coaster go three player would
tell you to not use the small cork
screws ever they are very very unsmooth
they hurts they have killed people in
the past don't use them the large cork
screws are a lot better and it's just
kind of more realistic as you can see
this is a very large and spread out
cobra roll but it is a lot smoother and
better in general than having that very
not so very smooth very small corkscrew
this would actually seem like a perfect
place to add a mid-course brake one like
no I wouldn't do that's like pump do
that no we're not going to do that I
need to find a way to somehow get back
to where I just was I don't think this
is really the best of ideas that I could
have done here let's see can I do
something like that because of course
I'm gonna have to head back into the
station after
so I have to be careful with what I do
over here that would actually look
pretty good I think maybe a small zero
zero or something that could be done
yeah one thing to say about B&M
sit-downs as well as being flawless is
that they are very formulaic they really
aren't too unique and they kind of
simple which is also something that I
think some people like to bash being a
Mon is that the tracks are very similar
but even though this means that you know
there is a very certain kind of style
that you have to follow when it comes to
the layouts it is always cool to just
kind of your own elements into it as
long as you kind of keep that basic
structure of lift Hill first half of the
coaster and then either a break run or
not and then the second half of the
coaster where it's kind of slower has
some helixes and smaller inversions but
we'll get to that in a tiny second as
soon as I find a good way to get to the
other side without this looking very
awkward in the end because it isn't
really working out too well right now
like this is not very smooth when I do
something like that
now that's the question right here I
generally like to not use these things
where when I'm talking about using a
hill like that to go straight and then
go gentle against because as you can see
it is a very uncertain drop like that I
always like to just use the one that
goes down like that which is a lot
smoother and I like to avoid having to
do this thing
by all means seriously one thing that
you can for example do to make that a
tiny bit less jerky is to for example at
the bank like that which although it
looks a bit dodgy
I find looks a tiny bit better than
doing something like this because as you
can see this really does get a tiny bit
not very smooth but that is kind of up
to your own opinion and ideas about that
you could probably do some other stuff
as well but I always kind of like to do
this as well in any case this is still
not really working out over here I was
hoping that this would somehow give me a
good-looking Hill but no such thing it's
still really it
goes down way too fast so yeah I need to
find something else to do over here I
mean the lift Hill that's the issue the
lift Hill right here is right in the
middle of whatever I want to try where
you're stuck at some given points just
kind of add some slight alterations in
the track you don't have to completely
redo anything everything like what I
could have done and for instance is just
kind of have moved this thing and done
the Cobra row as well but just kind of
do it in a different way but that is not
going to work out because of that so I'm
actually going to move this loop and see
if I can do it like that because
seriously it is a bit of a shame to just
real to just remove your entire layout
or whole parts of your layout when
something doesn't really work out you
can always just remove or change a
earlier elements and then just rebuild
rebuild it in a same way that you did it
before which is kind of like there's
some small changes but we still have
these same elements but we still got
somewhere else so where you get stuck
somewhere you don't really have to
remove the entire thing anyway I need to
kind of hurry up here I'm taking way too
much time to say stuff yeah I was hoping
that I could maybe get like a smooth
over-banked turn but that is probably
not going to happen over here nope that
is definitely not going to work let's
see then like one thing that would be
amazing is if this would fit which it
does kind of look like it could happen
like honestly that doesn't even look
that bad yeah I want to do something
like this and not go over there anymore
since being up sit-downs as well as
being in florida least once again like
those two things are usually quite
compact they're not spaghetti ball and
compacts but they are quite compact
especially compared to hyper coasters
and the like so always just kind of keep
your yeah obviously is kind of keep them
small don't get too far away from the
station that's one really big tip that I
would give never get too far away from
the station
but this is really working out too well
and the game says that this is allowed
but I would not allow this this does not
look like enough clearance if you are
worried about whether it's going to give
something enough clearance or not so you
can always contest the ride display it
and see how much room is left and
whether a track will actually chop
people's heads off and that doesn't work
because I'm an idiot
hold on you need to leave that mode for
that only then can you actually pause it
yeah and though that does look pretty
safe I don't think I would do that
seriously people could reach out their
arms and touch the track if they were
very tall this is slightly too close to
it I would say yeah I wouldn't do that
not to mention that over here it's
pretty close as well
ouch that is quite painful is really
quite painful man what the hell am I
even going to do with this I'm seriously
I'm pretty stuck over here don't we
don't wanna make this tutorial too long
just because I'm stuck over here I'm not
just going to do it I'm just going to do
it like the clearance test it passed the
clearance test and if a roller comes
through pauses the clearance that's that
you can do it you're really so desire
[ __ ] it I'm gonna try it anyway
not going to stretch this out too long I
can add a zero-g roll over here but I
don't know about that speed as you can
see having that testing while you work
on it can actually be really handy since
it doesn't even make that Cobra roll
this is not a realistic amount of trains
that are realistic amount of cars though
which is quite important as well like
you need a realistic amount of cars
otherwise it'll slow down much more buts
yeah this definitely doesn't make it
there is a remedy for that though it
pretty easy remedy we're just gonna work
this thing into the ground yeah whatever
and this might look stupid but you can
always just kind of cover this up with
terrain stuff on the sides and it's
really not too much of an issue I would
say definitely you definitely can get
away with doing stuff like this
how many be names do this many be names
kind of go into the terrain and just
kind of have some small walls on the
sides so that should be fine
let's see now some half-loop here we go
and in a way this also makes my job a
tiny bit easier since I can just kind of
go down like that's and then go into the
latter part of the ride where we might
actually have a corkscrew
like right here already might want to do
that though that is pretty soon isn't it
yeah that is too soon I would say just
one more of these and then we should be
good to go honestly now I don't want to
have any jerky transitions generally
what you'd want to have is if you come
out of a curve let's say for instance we
are banked in this direction and if you
Bank it that way don't do that when you
want to have a corkscrew in this
direction since as you could see it's
gonna Bank in that way it's gonna back
back but then it's gonna Bank back in
the same direction once again it's gonna
be really jerky if you had a coin screw
in that direction it's gonna be really
smooth but you're really gonna have to
fit that in well but what you don't
really need to worry about is like over
here we have a curve that banks in that
direction but I also want to have a
corkscrew that goes in the same
direction and this would be really jerky
and painful and we don't really want to
have that also that speed is perfect
that is about the speed that you're
looking for could be slightly faster
that's actually alright yeah that's
alright but as you can see it rise it
all rights and it goes through the
corkscrew or be it a tiny bit slow the
thing just is that it's joki over here
so I usually just like to end the curve
like that since that means that you
don't really have too much of a bank at
the end and then if you add a large go
through in that direction you should be
fine honestly now I'm looking for
something that can end the ride in a
nice way
since right after this element I would
say is when we start with the latter
part of the right no more loopings no
more cobra rolls nomer zero zeros just
helixes bunny hops and hog screws things
like that's small airtime Hills and
curves is usually what you have at the
letter end of the ride helix could be
kind of cool but I don't think that
would fit too well in this ride honestly
yeah it should be working pretty nicely
over here
that's alright still kind of worried
about that that speed though that is
slightly too slow yeah I cannot do
something about that is it a good idea
to try to do something about that hmm
yeah I'm just gonna work this thing into
the terrain I would know and you can't
do that I don't want to touch the ground
usually they don't do that so I'm just
gonna have to live with this we're just
gonna end the write like that that
should be alright just a couple of small
curves at the end and that should finish
it off nicely we always want to leave
some room at the end of the station just
for the brake run as well as the thing
where it saves the cars which is
something that I'll go to in a tiny bits
it should be alright honestly not the
best thing but yeah that's too many
curves that's many weird curves in a row
I don't really want to have that
something like that's good work
probably but then again not really does
it I'm gonna I'm gonna look into
something completely different since
this part of the layout just doesn't
work and yeah this is part of making
layouts just trial and error all over
the place right there a corkscrew over
here could fit it's not coming too close
to the station I would always say save
at least one tile away from the station
since at the station you're gonna want
to save some space for the station
itself maybe even a queue or something
this is about the distance that I would
like to have from the station at most
so yeah this should be pretty safe now
after we do this we can actually have
some funny curved action without really
yeah having too many problems with that
only issue is you know it it kind of is
a tiny bit small it's a bit of a sudden
ending right there so yeah what do you
want to do with that I don't even really
know who thing is you could say but
silver at what is wrong I mean it works
up perfectly you can go up and do that
there's two problems with this there's
not enough space for the break section
at the end as well as the transfer tract
that we would like to have you generally
want a pretty large straight piece of
track before it enters the station and
also small hills like this just before
the station is something that you want
to completely avoid so we're not going
to quite do that yeah I need to find a
different way back into the station
honestly I don't know how well this
could work though it's not enough room
for lots this is an issue this really is
an issue and this was already curved
wasn't it a different idea then
this would have been great only wasn't
too small
no none of that is actually going to
work out I would like to have a helix
though at the end that would be amazing
so yeah if you're stuck like that you
don't really know what to do bunny hops
are the thing that you can add to small
air times Hills
they're fun they look pretty good and it
just means that you save a tiny bit more
space and we can go into that direction
have some curves have a helix up rather
than having that you know very unsmooth
little thing and unbanked and there is
enough space left for the breaks and the
transfer and the transfer track so I
would say that concludes our trek over
here yeah I think that's pretty good
one last one lost test and then it
should be alright do we want to do a POV
do we really want to do that damnit
I suppose that's good though yeah just
kind of tests how smooth it is just
throw out your wheeze and the man boobs
are jiggling and yeah this looping
actually it's an alright speed something
that I would like to say is that while
you're on the ride sometimes it almost
seems like the speeds are different to
me at least sometimes when I'm on the
roller coaster it almost feels like it's
a tiny bit slower than when you look at
it from a distance and also something to
keep in mind is that in volcko ii three
posters tend to look slower than in real
life like real life coasters do slowed
down quite a bit in their inversions
there aren't really quite as fast but
many people tend to make their rights in
roller coaster k3 really fast since it
looks like a realistic speed but kind of
keep in mind that in roller coaster in
three it's gonna look a tiny bit slower
than it would have been in reality not
really but I don't know it just I just
kind of have that impression and many
other people do too at least that I know
of so that's something small to keep in
mind and last thing is the color scheme
and this really comes down to whatever
you feel like is a good idea but
something that you can do which I'm not
a fan of not really a fan but sometimes
I do it too honestly it's a really handy
thing is just look up color schemes on
the into
that there is a really handy website for
that it's called color combos comm there
are other websites as well I'm not
advertising this website or anything but
I just kind of like color combos but
there's some other stuff as well but
color combos at the in the middle of the
page they have like their latest color
combos and popular community combos and
that's where some really awesome colors
are but if you've like seen many roller
coasters and have done it quite often
before as in coloring roller coasters
oops that was kind of awkward then it
shouldn't really be too much of a
problem
a very common color scheme is to have
white supports that this is in game
color thing works different
yeah Wesley white supports even that
that makes the supports white and yeah
white supports basically and a red or
blue track which is quite common many
people like to do it's very I don't know
it's very standard though I'm not really
a big fan of it but I would definitely
just recommend checking out Cola combos
also what I should I would recommend is
don't be me get him get CP cisco's
Benham retexture since that thing
changes the colors which means that you
can change the color of the supports
without changing the color of these what
are they called cross ties something
like that these little middle parts in
the track and that is really something
that's really handy since we kind of
don't want that to be the same color
also it looks really awesome overall but
yeah that's it I'm just gonna take a
color combo from our color combo thing
right there from the color combos calm
and they're saying that yeah that purple
might actually go really well with this
color not on this roller coaster though
no I would say maybe something like aqua
I thought in purple is a really amazing
color combo 9'o of but yeah that's
pretty much how that works I've really
been going off topic for the last couple
of minutes so sorry about that this is
basically the standard to BM sit-down
kind of recipe this is how you cook a
real BM sit down remember this is
definitely not the best me and I'm
sitting down that I've ever built
there's definitely a couple of problems
with it I think it could be a tiny bit
more compact and things but this is the
basic recipe have a lift he'll have a
couple of standard elements some larger
Hills some loopings some over-banked
curves
some Cobra rolls and then you answer the
later section the latter half of the
roller coaster where you just keep it to
very small zero-g rolls corkscrews bonny
hills and helixes and that's how it
works as long as you follow that formula
then you should be pretty fine so thanks
for watching guys I hope you've learned
something from this tutorial and I'll
see you all next time or something
hopefully maybe probably I don't know in
any case good bye